The fast Fourier transform is
an instance of the discrete Fourier
transform, which as we've said has its
own significance in various branches of
mathematics, physics and engineering,
signal processing most especially.
In the study of algorithms,
however, the fast Fourier transform
is most interesting for its role and
a very practical and very fast way of
convolving two sequences of numbers.
We'll illustrate
convolution by an example.
We're given two sequences of numbers
shown here, we'll call them a and b.
And we want to obtain a new sequence
defined by this formula here,
where the kth element in the sequence
is the sum from 0 to k over i and
ai times b sub k minus i.
We can visualize convolution by
reversing the order of b and lining it
up with a, so that the the 0th element
of b is under the kth element of a.
This is the alignment for k equals 0,
then we multiply all elements that
overlap and add up these products.
For k equals zero,
this is 2 times 1, which is 2.
So we'll write down
that C0 is equal to 2.
For k equals 1, we shift the sequence
over, multiply the corresponding
elements and add those up, that is
a total of zero and that becomes C1.
For K equals 2 we shift
the B sequence over again,
multiply the corresponding elements and
add them up for a total of 5 and
we continue sliding b along doing
these products and then summing all
things together and we keep doing this
until there is no more overlap left.
Convolution has many applications, but
the one that will be most convenient for
us to talk about is
multiplying polynomials.
Given two coefficients of polynomials,
we can find the coefficients of
the product just by convolving
the two sequences of coefficients.
In fact, we can easily repeat
the example we just did, but
in the context of
polynomial multiplication.
First, I lined things up, so
that we get the constant terms and
that product is two.
Then we line them up, so
that we get the linear terms, 0 times x.
we get the quadratic terms.
5 time x squared and so forth and so on.
How long does this process take?
Well, for each element in the longer
sequence, we had to do as many
multiplications and additions as there
are elements in the shorter sequence.
Sometimes it will be a little
shorter around the edges,
because the shorter one ran off
the edge of the longer one.
But on average,
it was at least about half.
Therefore, we can say that convolving
two sequences via the naive
strategy outlined here, takes theta
n times m operations where n and
m are the lengths the sequences.
The Fourier Transform will give
us a way to improve on this.